okay so spiderman no way home is packed
with easter eggs things you missed and a
lot of insane details that make it one
of the densest comic book movies of all
time the film expertly brings together
stories spanning 20 years in order to
give us one of the biggest spider-man
celebrations ever throughout this video
we're going to be breaking it all down
and there might even be some little
cameos of our own so make sure you stay
until the end and the movie centers
around tom holland's peter parker as he
accidentally breaks up in the multiverse
and brings across several versions of
himself from the marvel universe this
includes tobey maguire and andrew
garfield and some scenes that would make
stanley proud although he passed away
before he ever got to see the film the
creative team somewhat kept a cameo of
him in the movie and when peter visits
the donut shop at the end we can see
that mj is serving an old man this is
actor ed force who according to the
script is supposed to be a stanley
look-alike this was done deliberately to
make us look at the actor and get a
feeling that we knew him from somewhere
even though we can't put our finger on
it expertly laced into this scene the
audience get the exact same feeling that
mj has upon peter reintroducing himself
to her she knows him from somewhere but
can't tell where and i absolutely love
this line the script even mentions that
she has deja vu and a slight sense of
recognition but she can't put a finger
on it mj wears the black dahlia necklace
in the final scene which you might
remember was gifted to her at the end of
far from home in the movie it was
initially a fully formed flower but
after it was destroyed it fractured into
pieces like how we see still she has a
reason to wear it and her
subconsciousness is drawn towards it
stanley co-created spider-man with steve
ditko and he too gets a little reference
with his name appearing in graffiti
during the scene in which mj and peter
are on the roof there's also a note to
him on the feast van and when may pulls
up to the sanctuarium we can see it on
the side mr dikovich was actually based
on ditko and though we don't get a cameo
by him we do somewhat get a nut of the
character with a guy asking for rent at
the end of the film give me rent you'll
get your rent when you fix this damn
door
the movie of course brings all the
live-action spider-man together and it
plays upon several me oh oh no oh no the
multiverse it's breaking open
what's up paul first and foremost
congratulations on becoming a father
that's truly awesome man thanks for
having me on this i appreciate it
my two favorite easter eggs for
spider-man no way home were a real treat
for me because when i found out that the
three spider-man were going to be in one
movie i wanted two things from it one
was the classic pointing meme and we got
it we got it in a non-traditional way in
the movie but i think we got it in a way
that made the most sense zendaya's mj
calls out peter and then the three of
them are like which one is it they point
to each other you is it you is you do
because i'm peter i think that was a
very clever way to do it and then the
second thing that i wanted was for them
to talk about the fact that toby
maguire's peter parker spider-man has
organic web shooters he creates his own
and i wanted them to talk about that and
address that since tom hollins and
andrew garfield spider-man can't do that
they have to have web cartridges and
they addressed it perfectly and they
even kind of made fun of it a little bit
when they ask does it come out of
anywhere else or is it only out of your
wrist and you know have you ever had
like a web block before and that was
that leaked video that we saw where we
thought andrew garfield was saying webb
blood
but it was a web block and of course
he's talking about spider-man 2. i did i
had a web block why oh existential
crisis i thought that was executed
perfectly and those were the two best
easter eggs for me because they were
really a dream come true
who managed to lock that down now there
is of course another character who
everyone knows is spider-man and that is
miles morales first introduced in into
the spider-verse we also know that his
uncle aaron is in the mcu and that he's
played by donald glover eva mentions his
nephew in homecoming and though miles
hasn't been cast yet there is a line in
no way home that's somewhat an odd to
him oh man i'm sorry i don't pause this
there's gotta be a black spider-man
somewhere at the end now if you look at
the script this line has a little note
on the end of it that isn't said in the
movie which i like to think is setting
up a live action miles for the future
now on top of the spider-man all of
peter's villains come back and there are
several points in the movie where they
repeat phrases from their prior films
you know i'm something of a scientist
myself you know
i'm something of a scientist myself
my back
my back
my back it's kind of stiff from all the
swinging i guess oh yeah no i got a
middle back thing too really yeah
the power of the sun
in the palm of my hand the power of the
sun in the palm of my hand
the power of the sun
the palm of your hand go get him tiger
go get him tiger
or should i say
spider
i miss the part where that's my problem
no me this isn't my problem it's not my
problem
there's so many details like this and
lots of foreshadowing in the film one of
the major events that happens is the
death of anne mae which actually gets
hinted towards right before she passes
there's a really cool scene where
peter's spider sense kicks in and he
starts to walk around happy's apartment
looking for danger the first thing peter
says is may which is very much hinting
towards her death at the hands of the
green goblin if you look at peter's hand
it actually starts to move towards
norman when he's surveying the room but
he's interrupted by sandman which is
when he drops it now speaking of spider
sense we see it in action just before
the mirror dimension scene strange
pushes peter into his astral form and he
attempts to grab the magic box from him
that we're not gonna try to pronounce
here what is that
it's an ancient relic the mackinac davis
however peter's own constantly moves and
reacts to him attempting to grab it
which shows his spider sense is very
much what happens when his body's on
autopilot if you look closely at his
head you can see some of a wavy line
effect coming off it and this is exactly
what it looked like in the comics
there's also a squirrel there which
no
no i can't it can't be him
now the spider sense keeps him out of
harm's way and the aforementioned scene
with osborne shows that it will pick up
danger in his subconscious even if he
can't consciously determine where it is
during the scene in which a brick is
thrown through the window though matt
murdock catches it if you look closely
at the footage you'll see peter raises
his hand up to stop it because of his
spider sense now the opening of the
movie happens immediately after the
first post credits scene of far from
home they even brought back the actors
from that film and if you look behind mj
you'll see that there's three people
standing there with a guy on the right
holding his phone up to film the web
head go back to far from home and we can
catch those same people including the
guy with the phone showing how much they
tried to line up these moments it's at
this point that we hear the words
and this is actually a throwback to when
toby maguire's version was unmasked on
the train
you might also catch that this is penn
station which was also shown at the end
of venom let there be carnage in the
post-credits scene the newscaster who
drops the report is an anchor that's
actually appeared throughout the mcu at
several points and he's somewhat of a
mainstay when it comes to reporting on
the events of the universe peter swings
throughout times square and we can also
see several posters for rogers the
musical which of course popped up
throughout hawkeye there's also a giant
sign with his face cut in half that has
the mask on one side and peters on the
other this is iconography that often
pops up in the source material whenever
peter's spider sense goes off it also
showed up in civil war right after his
identity was revealed which is of course
an element that this movie is based upon
he and mj land on the queensborough
bridge and you might recognize this from
the original spider-man movie green
goblin dropped mj over the edge of it
and she somewhat ends up falling over in
this one too when peter jumps down with
it it is a bit of a reach that i'll
admit now there are other things from
that movie that appear namely the
roosevelt island tramway car which
goblin 2 held up in that movie this also
popped up an amazing spider-man 2 and
peter was researching his father's
secret lab and it's one of the first
many bits of the film that foreshadowed
the two showing up we then catch flash
thompson and throughout the movie he
promotes his book flashpoint available
in all good bookshops now a flashpoint
might actually be a nod to the dc's
story of the same name in which flash
broke the multiverse open after
travelling back in time that story is
going to be explored in the upcoming
flash movie and this might be marvel
doing a bit of a joke to dc as they got
their first in the films better not be
though or i'm going to kick off i'm
gonna kick off if there's any jokes
about anything
now there's such a slick moment here and
i love how when peter travels past flash
thompson you can see him basically web
up the grate drop through the hole and
then pull a grey back on top so that he
has something for his webbing to hang
off when he goes into the sewer very
very slick and he travels through the
subway which is where toby fought
sandman in spider-man 3. as he exits the
sewer he pulls the manhole cover closed
using his web and according to the
easter egg special features on the
blu-ray this is a nod to the final shot
of andrew garfield in the amazing
spider-man 2 in which he grabbed a cover
and swung it around with his whips peter
is now outside delmore's which you might
recognize as being the delhi from
homecoming if you cast your mind back to
that movie then you'll recall it was
destroyed after the quote-unquote
avengers bank robber scene and this now
has a number three on the sign as a
reference to the third spider-man movie
this also appeared in the extended
version of far from home which was only
released in theaters and if we count
that then yeah they are right this is
its third appearance other callbacks to
homecoming happened just after this with
peter wearing the i survived my trip to
new york t-shirt that he wore after tony
took his suit away holland has been on
the heavy spoilers diet though and
bulked the [ __ ] up you can actually see
this in the shirt and if you place them
side by side you'll notice it was way
baggier on him in homecoming you chump
see you chump
i love this ampeda walks around the home
closing all the blinds the last one he
gets to won't close and he whips his
shirt a really nice bit of attention to
detail later on they end up covering
these windows up with newspapers and we
can read one with the headline web of
destruction he's taken away by damage
control who debuted in homecoming and i
love how the opening of the movie has
the likes of them the t-shirt and
dalmore all calling back to holland's
first movie for the first act of the
film when damage controls show up we can
also catch a photo of mjnet at the
homecoming party in which peter got
called penis parker
[Music]
so where's your pal spider-man let me
guess in canada with your imaginary
girlfriend
there's also a thai bomber which is a
not in and peter making a death star
together when he's questioned by damage
control he also wears the t-shirt that
he had on at the start of homecoming
when tony and happy dropped him off at
his home it's at this part that they
progress into the far-from-home easter
eggs and we get the edith glasses as
well as the iron spider suit charging
station damage control confiscate all
attack peter owns except for the iron
spider suit which he has on the bridge
now this is because it wasn't in the
charging station at the time and my
guess is that peter had it on during
those scenes when peter lands at the
bridge we can hear a male ai voice
instead of karen and this is because the
stark network is unavailable all the
drones in either glasses get seized so
it's likely that the entire network was
down which is why peter doesn't have
access to it now agent cleary says that
nick fury has been off world for a year
and this is because talos was
masquerading as him for the events of
the prior film throughout this is the
news report from the daily bugle which
features several images there's one in
which a sketch of spider-man can be seen
with the headline iron man jr which is
an in-joke on how peter is often called
up by people who think the mcu version
needs to stand on his own two feet the
magazine cover pops up later on in the
movie when we catch strange walking past
to stand peter gets green paint thrown
over him as well and this explains why
he has to turn the suit inside out as he
can't get it out until may steps in
there's also a news report and we can
see along the bottom that there's a
warrant out for night monkey calling
back to far from home they also use an
image of happy hogan looking like john
travolta and pulp fiction which is what
he donned at the start of iron man 3.
charlie cox pops up in one of the best
cameos in a movie and he catches a brick
that's thrown at him through the window
also look at this phone call yet
that's great thank you
i don't think anyone is on the other end
of that the guy doesn't even hang up now
john favreau of course played foggy
nelson in the daredevil movie and it's
nice that the two have a bit of back and
forth where matt says he needs to layer
up at this point the brick comes through
the window and if you pay close
attention to it you'll notice that the
believe has been misspelled to remove
the lie part of the word this could show
that mysterious supporters can't even
spell believe and that they were duped
by the master of illusions now mata's
big news for the mcu and kingpin of
course also appeared in hawkeye recently
maybe matt could have stopped by
westview in order to help wander learn
how to cope without vision
now according to vincent d'onofrio all
the netflix shows are now canon so you
better not embarrass me in front of
vanessa i've told her this video is
gonna get a lot of likes so if you're
enjoying it then please hit the thumbs
up button we do videos like this every
week so if you're enjoying it then use
your spoiler sense and make sure you
subscribe
oh no you you've hit the button too hard
the multiverse is cracked open again
so
happy's apartment is also full of cool
call backs and we see the badges that he
had on an iron man 3 when he was head of
security
later on we learned that there is a
fabricator there as well which showed up
at the end of far from home and right
beside that we can catch the word slot
which is a reference to the comic book
writer dan slott who happened to be at a
group dinner i attended a while back at
bear burger here in new york city
awesome burgers
awesome guy
i loved his spider-man run by the way
loved it superior spider-man he was
superior i wish dan slott was still on
that title because now it's unreadable
are you reading spider-man maybe you
like it i haven't read spider-man for a
while and it makes me sad especially
when i'm reminded of dan slott
oh well well well well well there's also
dumb e the robotic arm that was the
first invention tony stark ever created
this appeared in the iron man trilogy
because it got salvaged at the end of
iron man 3 and could then later be seen
in homecoming at stark tower thank you
grace and dummy plays a big part later
on as peter webb's goblins hand to it
which is something that he's done in a
lot of the movies he webbed tony's hand
to the door in civil war webbed aaron's
hand to his car boot in homecoming and
the guy just does it as a reaction to
stop people from moving peter and mj
facetime one another and above her head
you can catch several of the sketches
that she drew during detention in
homecoming this includes coach wilson
along with several photos from venice in
far from home curtis betty brant
reporting on peter going back to school
and this pulls from the storyline brand
new day in which he became a reporter
instead of a desk clerk for the daily
bugle the movie is clearly based on the
comic one more day which led into a
brand new day and it cribs several plot
points from it after civil war peter
traveled to doctor strange to see if
there was a way to help without may who
had been shot by one of kingpin's
assassins the sanctorum was extremely
run down and this is somewhat mirrored
in the movie when we catch it covered in
snow strange tried several spells but he
couldn't heal may and thus peter turned
to mephisto not him again not that
squirrel now mephisto safe here in
exchange for peter and mary jane's love
and to make sure no more assassins were
sent after those close to him he erased
the knowledge from people's minds that
he was spider-man one of the signs makes
peter out to be the devil possibly
linking to this or possibly a massive
reach or reach across the multiverse
hey paul josh from den of nerds here and
my favorite spider-man no way home
easter egg has to be the lighting on
toby mcguire's dick even though i had
bought a ticket and was sitting in a
theater the lighting looked so weird i
wasn't sure if what i was looking at was
actually real there are actually a
couple that i really enjoyed i liked it
when betty said go get him tiger when
reporting from midtown highs is
obviously something that mary jane says
from the comics and i love when they
sprinkle in those sweet little call
backs to the funny book you also hear
the do a flip guy from shangshi and
spider-man homecoming and that dude's
just hilarious
and then randomly the person that says
are you gonna have his spider babies is
apparently zendaya's personal assistant
which you told me about paul so that i
actually looked like i knew what i was
doing in this segment on your video
thanks a lot bud thanks josh for
upstaging me on my video voice sounds
much better than mine much deeper and it
really pisses me off he's got the same
microphone it does my head in every time
i watch it now inside the school we see
the wall of legendary signs figures that
popped up in homecoming amongst caesar
howard stark it's going from captain
america and hank pym they have a trail
vk set out for peter and after the movie
i'm unsure how this would work with
everyone forgetting but we could be
stuck here all day arguing about the
ending of this film now there is a photo
of mj and peter and venice and if you
look closely at it you can see mr
harrington has cut himself out and
pasted himself into it harrington
actually appeared in the incredible hulk
as a scientist and since then he's gone
on to get a job as a teacher at the
school there's also a trophy for peter's
decathlon which was a big plot point in
homecoming some suggest that parker's
powers include the male spiders ability
to hypnotize females which he used to
seduce jones watson into his cult of
personality now on the rooftop mj reads
an article about how peter has
hypnotized her and this foreshadows the
ending of the movie in which he
hypnotizes everyone into forgetting
about him we see dummy slowly building
peter's death star and it then gets
dropped on the floor when mae brings the
mit letter in this is just like how ned
dropped it upon finding out that peter
was spider-man and the lego death star
easter eggs they don't stop there now in
homecoming we were introduced to ned
through the palpatine figure that he
held up to peter's head this is the
first time that we met the character and
peter actually kept this figure with him
in the apartment at the end of the movie
it pops up in a quick shot and it
definitely reminds the character what
he's fighting for after seeing a hanging
wizard decoration for halloween peter
then has the idea to go to doctor
strange and whilst the central one
doesn't really look like the sorcerer if
you look at the heads on the left and
right they both have little beards that
make them look like steven from this
bonnie travels out of the sanctum which
we see is covered in snow we learned
this is because wong left open a gateway
that allowed a blizzard to come in we
saw these gateways in the doctor strange
movie and as one walks in you can catch
a contraption on the wall behind him
this is the bondage can i can i say that
this is the bondage suit that's strange
through on corcelius in that movie in
order to trap him in bondage yeah
bondage g james bondage i'm talking
about there
[Laughter]
you serious
it's here we discover one is the
sorcerer supreme as he got in on a
technicality during the snap and it's
how i'm gonna become the best
breakdowner ever after i kill every
other one out there i'm coming for you
ryan your chump shut the [ __ ] up
ryanairy now doctor strange also has a
mug that says for [ __ ] sake on it
which is what i imagine security at sony
to be thinking after all these leaks the
spell gets broken five times and this is
why five villains are able to come into
the mcu however there is also two peters
and venom who we learned in let there be
carnage finds out spider-man's identity
because of the symbiote collective
consciousness that spans through the
multiverse whilst this is going on we
can see strange's helper and that little
ornament thingy falling apart which also
happened in thor ragnarok the shape of
the lizard is formed in the multiversal
web and later on when the same thing
happens at the end of the movie there's
more figures you can catch this includes
craven the hunter the scorpion rhino and
possibly madame webb who we know is
getting a spin-off movie very soon
according to the easter egg special
features there's also the forum
spider-man there but i can't see it so
maybe you should go and watch that
breakdown instead you sucker see you
chump
now we go to the bridge scene and we get
peter flying in on the wingsuit which he
also used during homecoming peter rush
has passed several cars and in one we
can see kids watching the daily bugle
report that's being filmed from a
helicopter this is actually showing the
camera shot from when he was just waving
at the chopper and as we know it's
normally a seven second delay on
broadcasts going live now darkhawk
arrives and tries to hold him up to the
daily bugle helicopter this is symbolic
on a number of levels as it's pretty
much showing how everything the bugle
threw at him has been transformed into a
weapon that has the power to kill him
just as much as his enemies the river is
the same one ark died in during
spider-man 2 and we get one of the
license plates that teases his debut you
can catch 6-3 asm-3 which stands for the
year 1963 amazing spider-man issue
number three this introduced the villain
who arrives not long after and starts
doing more reaches than we've done in
this whole video the taxi behind peter
also has the numbers 1228 possibly a
reference to spider-man 12 which
featured dog hawk that was then fleshed
out further during a flashback in issue
28 just googling numbers all day i was
and to be fair i did say we would be
reaching now at one point peter climbs
up one of the cars as it falls which is
somewhat reminiscent of when toby
climbed at the brick wall during his
fight with harry and spider-man 3.
there's more callbacks to that scene as
peter is wearing a similar suit to what
toby head on and at one point he gets
his tie sliced in half this is something
that also happened to toby during that
movie when harry cut it and i love how
these two moments just line up so
perfectly now the car that gets thrown
over the edge which peter webs up also
looks a lot like the one that went over
the bridge in the amazing spider-man and
if it's not well sometimes you have to
let your boy reach i've warned you
enough times about that now darkhawk
goes to crush peter's head and this is
something that he did in the bank scene
against toby maguire wakanda forever
peter then takes the boomers tech before
the goblin arrives to ruin everything
like the next guy in the video hey paul
ryan from screen crush here congrats on
having twins you're gonna make a great
dab yeah man congratulations babies are
weird and squishy but if you want one
that's awesome okay so here's an easter
egg for your breakdown video when norman
osborne tells the goblin to go away like
gollum i never
come back
the scene is shot to parallel when peter
number two gave up being spider-man and
spider-man 2. and that's it that's all
you get from me stop being lazy do your
job shut the [ __ ] up ryanairy must close
the multiverse shut the [ __ ] up
can't have losers like ryanairy ruining
the video
now the comic spider-man no more was
also brought up in spider-man 2 as one
of the daily bugle headlines we now know
from concept art that it was originally
going to be america's chavez who brought
toby and andrew across but because the
release date of the movie switched up we
got ned doing it instead in the basement
of the sanctorum they start to look on
tick tock by the green goblin and get
these funny little elf videos mj also
picks up a goatee template box and hey
strange i'm not judging the guy's hands
are still shaking so yeah you do what
you gotta do to keep that trim mate now
ned's laptop also has a this is fine
sticker on it which is a carryover from
homecoming showing that the guy is still
using the same one electro becomes the
first target and he appears in a
terminator-esque lightning storm but
naked just like ani did later in the
movie when his powers start up you also
get a bowl covering his face that's very
reminiscent of the mask that he wore in
the comics originally when peter cheeks
it out with him he ends up tying
together several webs and this is
extremely similar to what andrew
garfield's version did in his second
film salman helps out and the fight ends
with electro saying that he hates the
woods i hate the woods i'm at the
universe this is because there isn't
really that much electricity there
unlike the city which is of course
filled with it now he hates the woods
and i hate sand because it gets
everywhere and we have a nice bit of
attention to detail when peter smacks
samantha's hand in order to say thanks
he actually hits it so hard that it
completely disappears and i i appreciate
that let's just hope it's not the hand
that he uses for
i'm sorry i can't say that now after
learning goblin is at feast peter heads
there outside there's a post of a
spider-man and at the beginning of far
from home he of course did the event
with feasts for aunt may this is being
spray painted with mysterio was right
and we can also see that the phone
number is 1 800 give feast which is
because it's a charity now though it
seemed like he destroyed the goblin
identity we can't catch from norman's
clothes that he's still there the
goblins colours are of course green and
purple and norman still having these
here shows that it's buried in his
subconscious may also wears blue and red
which are of course the colours of
spider-man it's not too long before
norman kills her and her standing here
in these colours sets up them being
opposite sides later on
and i don't mean just in the cosmos i
mean in his mind
now i love how you can catch norman in
the background stealing donuts and it
really paints him out as a sympathetic
figure
go to the daily bugle studio which is of
course an infowars-esque outlet it's had
a major update since the start of the
movie and much like alex jones j jonah
is now pushing supplements we can see a
report asking why spider-man hates the
national monuments and this has the
washington monument on it which he
climbed up in damage during the events
of homecoming this of course also
foreshadows how he destroys the statue
of liberty at the end of the film and my
god the guy is a spider menace they
return to the sanctuarium and there's
several nodes to other movies namely the
villain's deaths and how he left them
peter then grabs strange's box and he
opens portals to trap him with his own
webs which feels like it was ripped
right out of the portal games if you
look at the last one you can see
spider-man actually holding onto his
foot with his web which dangles in
mid-air strange then pushes him out of
his body into his astral form in a shot
that plays heavily on the way this was
done by the ancient one in doctor
strange strange plans to send him into
the mirror dimension and the multi the
multiverse let's break it open again
hello paul it's me eric voss traveling
across the youtube multiverse to share
with you some easter eggs i spotted a no
way home and you know what i'm actually
gonna do it in a nice wholesome way
because i'm really deeply infatuated
with you and your work and i i don't
want commenters not in on the joke to
think that there's some drama between us
like there is between you and that
garbage peddler ryan airy at screen
crush so here we go strange chase is
after peter and he goes past a new stand
with several easter eggs firstly on the
top row is the time magazine issue which
has the iron man junior story that was
shown at the daily bugle report however
there's also liz allen on the cover of
people magazine she's calling peter a
liar and as we know from homecoming he
had her father locked up which may be
something that they explore in morbius
now at this point strange throws his
cloak after peter and wraps around his
neck which is a nod to the comic what if
spider-man had never become a crime
fighter this is also something that
popped up in the what if episode during
the zombie outbreak they travel into the
mirror dimension which is actually the
barrier between our two channels now
being severed bye-bye
[Music]
now they fly through a mere dimension
world and strange runs a train on peter
not not like that now this is something
that mysterio didn't borrow from home
and there was of course the famous train
scene in spider-man 2 which this one
seems to be the exact same model as
exact same model as that train what a
low point in the video you can tell i
wrote this tired after staying up all
night with the kids they never let me
get any sleep now if you pay close
attention to the trees in central park
you might notice all the leaves are
brown and the sky is grey this is
because the movie is set in the fall
which we can tell by the donut shop
owner telling mj to take the halloween
decorations down jones i told you to
take down the halloween decorations
actually that was sasha so enough
attitude just do it
the movie of course ends in winter due
to the snow so it looks like peter
actually spent a couple of months on his
own getting used to his anonymity before
going to her i love how as they travel
further into the desert the skyscrapers
turn themselves into cavernous rocks and
also makes me wonder if strange was
taking him out this far because it's a
good place to hide a body now peter
manages to beat strange by recognizing
the archimedean spiral and he then uses
the knowledge of maths to beat magic
from here they all go to happy's
apartment and as elektro passes the
camera it starts to glitch because he
interferes with the frequency of it they
build a new nano chip for dock awk and
the tentacle lights turn from red to
white after it's applied in spider-man 2
we learned that this differentiates when
they're in attack mode and win their
white occurs in control there's a really
cool bit of attention to detail when
peter throws his headset at the bench
and actually glitches the hologram as it
passes through it this didn't exist when
they were filming it and i love how
visual effects artists put these kinds
of things in as it shows they're paying
attention to what's going on in the
scene he gives the nano attack back to
peter and this smaller section of
nanobytes goes over his spidey suit to
create a new one that he wears
throughout the film we see norman
working away and in the bottom of this
shot you can catch the photo of iron man
that was based on the one used for
obama's presidential run just as peter's
spider sense kicks in we can catch
another nod to iron man 2 namely this
stark expo model hanging in the back
this was what tony used to create a new
element and it's so cool seeing at the
back of happy's goblin ends revealing
himself and he calls stockark a lap dog
which is somewhat of a call back to
earlier in the movie when otto said the
following fix
you mean like a dog
now peter goes toe-to-toe with him and
it's one of the most brutal fights in
the movie norman actually punches him so
hot at one point that it breaks one of
the stairs and god damn guys smashed him
like you should smash that like button i
like me and my viewers with my bad jokes
peter keeps punishing him until he
finally breaks him and he just goes
fully insane laughing out whatever peter
throws at him goblin kills mae and bombs
her and her home much like he did to
rosemary harris in the first spider-man
movie finish the prayer cut and may also
says the famous words
you have power
and with great power there must also
come great
responsibility
now she does change this up from the
more typical version however this is the
way it was originally phrased the first
time it was dropped in the comics may's
death scene is a really emotional one
and it happens in a similar way framing
wise to how ben passed away in the first
spider-man movie mj and ned bring across
toby and andrew and you can also catch a
sewing machine in the scene which gets a
bit of attention drawn to it the script
says that peter's new costume at the end
of the movie is somewhat of a
combination of toby and andrews and here
they are introduced together with a
focus on the sewing machine peter later
ends up using a machine to stitch them
all together and as i've been saying
it's all connected and it's grandma's
furniture also has plastic wrapping over
it which hey we've all got that kind of
relative in the family youtube itself is
very much like a family and
oh my god it's it's happening again
hello this is charlie from emergency
awesome my favorite spider-man no way
home easter egg is actually andrew
garfield saving tom holland's mj fully
redeeming himself for not being able to
save his own gwen stacy the minute we
all saw that trailer we saw her falling
we saw the hand reach out everyone
instantly thought wouldn't it be amazing
if andrew garfield is gonna be in this
film if he were the person to save mj
even andrew garfield himself said that
that was one of his favorite scenes in
the film he even revealed that was part
of the pitch that marvel and sony gave
to him that his character would be
having a moment like that in the film it
is the perfect example of fanservice
done right now andrew and toby very much
want to save peter from walking down the
dark path that they did toby talks about
how he went out to get revenge on the
person he believed killed uncle ben and
that this didn't fix the problem
i got what i wanted
it didn't make it better
they are in the movie he stops peter
from killing norman osborne which saves
him from the life of regret that toby
ended up having this is done in more
subtle ways with garfield who talks
about how after he lost gwen that he
ended up becoming more brutal try to
keep going try to keep being the uh
friendly neighborhood spider-man because
i know that's what she would have wanted
but at some point i just
i stopped pulling my punches now andrew
saves mj later on and in doing this it
stops tom holland's version from losing
the person that he loves the pair about
stop him from dealing with the same
mistakes that they did and thus they
very much right the wrongs of their own
past absolutely love how rather than
killing the villains the movie is about
curing them and it really shows that
this is what we do well well they do not
me i'm a kid and i'll probably spoil the
whole movie for you now they all bring
up the great power and great
responsibility line which shows it's
very much tied into the character's
origin story across the entire
multiverse from this point we learn a
lot about them and i haven't got a good
insert for a multiverse person here but
yeah here's everything always what's
going on guys it's michael roman from
everything always my favorite line in
the entire film is really one for me
that changes shapes after you've seen it
a couple of times when we first hear
toby tell andrew not to give up that
even though it was complicated him and
mj were able to make it work we're all
so hyped in that first viewing to see
toby and andrew on screen we take it as
face value and just information about
what happened in the sam raimi verse
after the film stopped getting made
maybe if you weren't completely
emotionally overwhelmed by the ending of
the first time you saw it in a way that
i was not you were able to put together
the foreshadowing if he was able to make
it work with his mj no matter how things
have gotten complicated in the mcu maybe
tom holland's peter parker and some
demos mj can make it work too but after
i had seen the film a couple of times i
realized the importance of that line
leading into act three is because andrew
moments later is going to put some
closure to what happened with gwen by
saving our mcu's mj and in that
coupled with the advice by toby he has a
chance now in his future
not to give up and even though it'll be
complicated make it work and so for me
that's one of my favorite lines because
it really gives me hope for the future
of andrew garfield spider-man
at the lab has the three pointing at
each other which cosmic wonder talked
about before this meme was also brought
up in into the spider-verse and the
group pointed each other three times in
the film this happens here in the lab on
the scaffolding and during the credits
we can catch a sketch of them or doing
it to threes the magic number sony also
just released a behind-the-scenes image
of the three pointing at each other i
think this might be the best photo ever
made absolute classic now just before
the fight they have some back and forth
banter and give nods to the villains
that they fought this includes thanos an
alien and venom and andrew talks about
the rhino who's just a russian guy in a
suit toby says he's amazing and a he's
the amazing spider-man do you see got
all it got all the easter eggs in this
video we do without that every easter
egg title we didn't lie now this scene
itself is absolutely amazing and we
watch as the spider-man learn to work
together their swing is incredible and
they help each other through the air
before landing on the statue of
liberty's head the statue now has a
captain america shield on it which shows
that he celebrated much in the same way
that tony was after endgame cap was
initially outlawed for breaking the
sokovia records but this shows that
society has accepted him once more with
open arms after he saved the universe
sam wilson has of course also taken up
the mantle and this has shown that it's
very much back in the official arms of
what the government deem is acceptable
when electro is in happy's home you can
also see the approval rating for the
changeup and it actually shows that
people are against them altering the way
it looks now speaking of approval
writing the approval writing of this
video is just about to drop so at the
end of the movie doc ock asks peter how
he's doing and peter says he's trying to
do better this is a direct call back to
spider-man 2 where peter says the exact
same thing after doco calls him
brilliant but lazy arker now i remember
you your connor student
tells me you're brilliant
he also tells me you're lazy
i'm trying to do better
you're all grown up
how are you
trying to do better
another moment i loved is when toby
mcguire talks about issues with his back
and andrew garfield has to crack it this
is a direct call back to mysterio actor
jake gyllenhaal who starred in the movie
brokeback mountain and wait that's not
right no
that's a
that that's a call back to spider-man 2
when tobin maguire hurts his back that's
that's what it is
that's why it's a great easter egg
also at the beginning of the movie peter
and mj stop on top of the queensboro
bridge this is also the same bridge
where i dropped my ex girl
there's also the same bridge where green
goblin notoriously dropped mj in
spider-man 1.
not someone i used to know are they
managed sorry about that they managed to
say
i love you greg
not really though you're crap now they
managed to save all their villains in
ways that reference the prior movies
andrew gets electrocuted and it looks
very similar to how it happened in the
amazing spider-man 2. you can actually
see it messes up his suit really badly
and if you zoom in on his mask it cracks
the lens on the iris both he and toby
get electrocuted but andrew recovers a
lot quicker and this is because he
insulated his suit during amazing
spider-man 2. some of the shots from the
original films are even used and there
are deleted moments from those movies
that show their transformations you
might remember that sandman was
transformed by a spinning super collider
and this is somewhat referenced in the
miniature device that turns him back
blizzard chases mj ned through a lab and
this calls back to when he fought
spider-man in the first garfield film at
this point osborne swoops in and says
can spider-man come out to play can the
spider-man come out to play
can spiderman come out to play
now destroying the box tears up in
reality and mj falls in a nod to gwen
stacy's death andrew saves her learning
from his mistakes and instead of using a
web to catch her he uses his arms to
cushion the blow at this point holland's
version thinks mj is dead as he didn't
see garfield save her he goes wild on
osborne and does some moves that are
very similar to the ones from the
playstation games however toby stops him
and this shares similar iconography to
when the character pulled the same
stance to marry jane in spider-man 2.
doctor strange carries out the spell to
make us forget forget someone someone i
can't quite remember and we see how the
world changes for the this character
sometimes
sometimes when you you try remember
something it breaks breaks open the
multiverse
what's up guys it's supes now it's at
this point in the movie that tom toby
and andrew say goodbye to each other the
trio hug it out and say the words this
is what we do which calls back to when
mae said it at beast
you know
it's what we do
look around you
this is what we do
we help people
that's what we do
peter wanted to back away from the
problem but he was inspired by me who
said that they help people this is a
line that has a lot of meaning for the
ending as the peters of course wanted to
heal the villains rather than hurt them
it shows that at their core they have
these values to help people no matter
what and it makes mae's inspiration hang
over the movie even more
the power of the gun in the palm of my
hand
dr octopus at your service
as andrew disappears we see him do a
peace sign this might actually be a
little nod to the meme where that kid
does one before disappearing ned nmj
getting to mit and peter ends up
studying for his ged she serves him a
coffee cup that has popped up in several
of the netflix shows and it says we are
happy to serve you which somewhat
symbolizes peter's new life choice now
from his room he listens to police
frequencies and this is a reference to
the opening of the playstation game in
which he does the same thing amaze grave
also has the exact words when you help
someone you help everyone this too also
popped up in the game and i love how
there's these consistencies throughout
all of the multiverse peter swings off
into the night sky and the script tells
us that he can now fully focus on being
spider-man we get a shot where his face
comes towards the camera and we zoom in
on his eye this is also the same way
that the first spider-man movie ended
and it very much brings everything full
circle from that movie 20 years ago
peter parker is no more but spider-man
is and rather than having to deal with
living a double life he can now focus on
the one that betters people's lives
instead of putting them in danger
[Music]
that's the full movie and huge thank you
to everyone who contributed to this
video all those that featured in it are
people i massively respect but this is
how i'm gonna act if i ever see you in
real life i'm just kidding i love you
one thousand the ad said three thousand
as for you watching i really hope that
you guys enjoyed it and we have a
breakdown of spider-man 2 on screen
right now hopefully you see over there
right after this but if not i'm gonna
forget you and never speak about you
again you weigh up what you want to do
and i hope you enjoy the rest of your
week you take care of yourself peace